[موسيقى]
تنص الماده 20 من الدستور اللبناني على
استقلال السلطه القضائيه لكنها تتحدث عن
مناطق دون ان تحدد محتوى هذه الضمانات
جميع القضاه في لبنان يجري تعيينهم من قبل
السلطه التنفيذيه المتمثله بمجلس الوزراء
سواء بناء على اقتراح من وزير العدل ام
غير ذلك مما يثير علامات استفهام عن مدى
استقلاليه القضاء عن السلطه السياسيه
لنبدا من مجلس القضاء الاعلى وهو اعلى
سلطه قضائيه في البلاد مهمته السهر على
حسن السيد القضاء وضمان استقلالته
يتالف من 10 اعضاء يعين مجلس الوزراء
ثمانيه منهم بشكل مباشر او غير مباشره ولا
تكون التعيينات في الجسم القضائي النافذه
الا بموافقه وزير العدل والحكومات في
لبنان تشكل من الاغلبيه البرلمانيه
المنتخب او بالتوافق السياسي بما يضمن
تمثيل الطوائف والقوه السياسيه وبالتالي
ينعكس هذا المشهد على التعيينات في الجسم
القضائي المجلس الدستوري هو هيئه مهمتها
مراقبه دستوريه القوانين والبت في الطعون
الانتخابيه تتالف من 10 اعضاء مناصفه بين
الطوائف تعينها السلطه التشريعيه وفي هذه
الهيئه تتداخل بوضوح المصالح الطوائف
والسلطه التشريعيه اين النواب الذين
ينتخبون بناء على انتماءاتهم الطائفيه
والسياسيه ما يدعو للشك في قدرتها على
ممارسه استقلاليهتها
المحكمه الجزائيه الخاصه المعروفه ايضا
بالمجلس الاعلى لمحاكمه الرؤساء والوزراء
تتالف من 15 من اعلى القضاه العدليين رتبه
سبعه منهم من النواب في البرلمان والسؤال
الاخطر عن مدى كفاءه النواب الذين لم
ينالوا اجازه في القانون اي يتولى منصب
قادم واي يشاركوا في محاكمات وبناء على
منطق المنصفه الطائفيه سواء بوجود نص او
بعرف مستمر منذ اتفاق الطائف الذي وضع
نهايه للحرب الاهليه عام 99 فان التعيينات
تراعي الانتماء الطائفيه وتزكيه الاطراف
السياسيه ويندرج تحت ذلك قضاه الفئه
الاولى التي لا يعينون من قبل مجلس
الوزراء وقضاه نيابات العامه التي يعينهم
ويسيروا العدل وقضاه المجلس العدلي الذين
يقترحهم وزير العدل ومجلس شور الدوله الذي
يعينه مجلس الوزراء وملاحظه
التعيين فان التجاذب القضائيه في قضيه
انفجار مرفا بيروت لا يبدو معزولا عن
الانقسام السياسي الراهن في لبنان خصوصا
ان بين المتهمين وزراء ومسؤولين امنيين
التدخلات السياسيه او توفير الغطاء
السياسي للقضاه ليس جديده وان وصل الى
مرحله فجه في قضيه بحجم انفجار المرفق